Very quietly and without much notice or fanfare
from corporate media for Bernie Sanders
taken a pretty decisive position in second
place of the 2020 democratic primary ahead
of Elizabeth Warren and is actually even statistically
tied for first place with Joe Biden.
In admittedly just one recent poll.
If you look at the last eight polls as of
a few hours ago, Bernie Sanders is either
statistically tied for second place with Elizabeth
Warren in two of the polls, 1413 and 1617
or in second place behind Joe Biden.
Bernie polling as high as 25 in the latest
Emerson poll as low as 14 in the latest USA
today poll, but in that USA today poll where
Bernie polls 14 Elizabeth Warren polls 13
this has not been covered very much or or
even really almost at all by corporate media.
I took a look at Google news and saw that
there's an article from VOC saying most voters
haven't picked anybody yet.
I saw an article from Newsweek which accurately
says Joe and Bernie are pulling away.
There's one good piece in the Boston globe
saying Bernie is back and has a shot.
At this thing.
Uh, now, of course we don't know what will
happen, but Bernie Sanders is suddenly in
a very strong position in national polling
with all of the normal caveats.
The caveat of course is much like with national
polling related to Donald Trump.
We need to understand that this is an electoral
college race.
In the end, the primary also is made up of
delegates that are garnered looking at each
individual States primary or caucus.
So let's look at some of those first primary
States.
And you know when you do that, it's also not
looking bad for Bernie in those first primary
States.
Bernie is in a statistical tie for first place
in Iowa, which is a first state to vote.
Bernie is in third place in New Hampshire
behind Biden and Buddha judge.
Bernie's tied with Elizabeth Warren for second
place in Nevada and Bernie is tied with Elizabeth
Warren for second place in South Carolina,
which will be the fourth state to vote.
So I get a lot of emails that are, you know,
this black and white thinking of, it's either
all this or all that.
Bernie is going to win all of these.
Bernie is going to win.
None of these.
This could go any number of ways and it's
going to be based on the momentum set by the
early States.
So if you're with Bernie, start to focus on
Iowa and New Hampshire and subsequently Nevada
and South Carolina, if you are with whoever,
increasingly that is the strategy.
We had debate number last night.
We have debate number seven on January 14th
and then voting starts on February three with
the Iowa caucuses.
Eight days later it will be the New Hampshire
primary on February 11th.
So Ken, Bernie Sanders wind, that's one question
that's often discussed.
The answer is yes, he can win.
What are you getting at when you asked that
question?
Are you alluding to DNC opposition to Bernie?
Are you alluding to voters?
Uh, taking to the ideology espoused by Bernie
Sanders?
Depending on what you're asking, there's a
different political analysis to be made.
Will Bernie win anybody claiming that definitively
is operating in mere speculation.
So I get a lot of Andrew Yang supporters who
will get in touch and say, David Yang will
win the nomination and is the only person
who can defeat Donald Trump.
Neither one of those claims is based.
In fact, I get people who say David Tulsi
Gabard is being railroaded, but she would
have won obviously if it weren't for the smears
against her.
And she is the only one who can defeat Donald
Trump.
We went through some of these claims before.
These are all mere speculation.
What we can say about Bernie Sanders is that
he is in this thing.
He is in this thing, even within the first
four primary States that will be sort of like
the momentum setters.
And at least in hypothetical polling with
Donald Trump, Bernie does well.
He does better than many candidates and he
does worse than Joe Biden.
And in some polls worse than Elizabeth Warren
nationally, although I'm trying to be as full
as possible here in thorough, uh, at in some
key States, uh, Bernie Sanders does better
than Elizabeth Warren in a hypothetical match
up against Donald Trump.
So go and work for it because it's going to
take work.
Uh, this is going to be, if, if you were to
say, will we know by March 1st who the nominee
is going to be and whether it's going to be
Bernie Sanders.
I don't know that we will know by March 1st,
but I think that by March 15th we will know
I'm going from memory.
I believe very early in March, maybe the third
or something like that.
There are a bunch of primaries including I
think here in Massachusetts.
Once those happen, we're going to have a very
good sense of who is in this thing, who is
not in this thing and who should be dropping
out because they have not garnered maybe even
any delegates in any of the first bunch of
primaries.
So we will certainly know by then last thing
on this, the role of impeachment in all of
this, there's this idea that once the impeachment
trial starts in the Senate, Bernie Sanders
and Elizabeth Warren are going to be pulled
out of their campaigns and in the Senate for
the trial and this will objective really hurt
them.
And it will boost Biden and, or Buddha judge,
the more establishment candidates.
I don't know that that is actually going to
happen.
You can speculate over whether that's the
goal of impeachment.
I think it's not, I think that Donald Trump
is getting impeached because Donald Trump
deserves to get impeached and there's going
to be a trial.
Uh, I don't believe that the full, uh, slate
of democratic challengers in, uh, of democratic
voters, uh, democratic reps who voted for
impeachment in the house of representatives
are saying, here's an idea.
I'm going to vote to impeach Trump to get
Bernie and Warren off the trail so that Biden
becomes the nominee.
I don't think that that's the case, but it's
speculative.
The more important part is, would it actually
work?
And I think that in a way you could be right
that not being on the campaign trail could
hurt Bernie or Warren.
But remember, most of what is going to be
going on by the time the Senate trial starts
is going to be via TV ads and campaigning
that doesn't require them to physically be
where the voters are.
And furthermore, there's a way in which being
prominently participating in the Senate trial
of Donald Trump's impeachment could actually
help Elizabeth Warren and Bernie Sanders that
Joe Biden won't have the benefit of that Pete
Buddha judge will not have the benefit of.
So I would not jump to that right away.
I don't think that there is actually evidence
of the motive.
And more importantly, I think if it is the
strategy that some are pursuing to get Bernie
and Warren off of the campaign trail, I think
he's going to fail.
And there's going to uh, uh, not, not work
at all and could even backfire.
We're going to talk about many things coming
up later today, including I want to get, I
never talked about this, but I do want to
talk about it.
Uh, Barron Trump and Gretta Toon Berg.
Why is it that Republicans went nuts when
one was mentioned, but said nothing about
Donald Trump bullying the other online?
I want to talk about that a little bit later.
We will get back to this conversation of martial
law and contesting the election results.
I want to get to that later.
In the show.
Also a really weird question related to my
recent appendectomy that I had, which I'm
going to humor the viewers with and actually
answer later today.
We will also take your phone calls upcoming,
makes sure you are following the at de Pacman
on Twitter.
Follow the David Pakman show at David Pakman
show and we've got a tremendous, tremendous
Friday show for you.
I will remind you just so people don't forget,
we have the Monday show and then we're on
break until almost the end of the year.
We're taking a week off next week.
Don't get scared.
The show is now going off the air.
We're just taking
a little vacation.